oh this guy flies he flies okay here we
go here we go nearly a hundred players
no no what am I getting 100 nearly 60
players for this tournament nearly 60
woman felled gambit maybe let's try this
all right click here bishop there they
might have been in pre move all right
now what is what is my queen
accomplished
what's even accomplished Wow
just went to b6 and then that's it I
thought rook e1 would have been good all
right this pond is gonna be a target I
could defend him though I'd love to move
just yet my bishop doing something
before let's go here no matter what
oh I should really watch about my queen
now should really wow I'm on this twice
a bishop moves my queen is hit my queen
I'm gonna take this next I think I think
it's safe to take it then we're gonna
try we are going to try Knight okay
let's get out of this Knight here I
still do this Queen move Queen here is a
threat in that rook 16 seconds 10
seconds
Bishop takes rook
and I'm getting more material actually
getting the bishop in the corner God
let's run home let's run home this game
is not going to end it's open stuff up
like this I don't want the night to jump
in there I mean here to f7 and point at
f2 let's just trade okay back back back
to tournament back back back to turbo
okay here we go
pie pans pie pants Benoni all right hang
on I don't want that expansion in there
all right let's just do this and then
maintain the pin oh my goodness the
queen is dead and then the rook just
like that don't blink don't blink
remember that remember not to blink I
didn't even have to react to that this
knight is pinned he is pinned so
actually okay back to Turman if that
knight on c6 went to like b4 I could
have made it on d7 nine six six and a
bunch of two's all right here we go
a quick resigner what is going on nine
nine six six Dylan Dylan has given me
beatings I think before counter strike
watch out for an f7 wow wow why am I so
stunned by that move put me right in my
place oh my goodness I would have
screamed I would have screamed oh man
get out of my house I don't need that I
don't need any dangerous stuff happening
to me he's got a go and this thing needs
to leave its to leave hang out of my
light square bishop get my pieces
working get expand with my spawn
that double pun is take here go here on
double my rooks are connected I could do
this and then my knight is a dangerous
piece a dangerous piece okay let's have
him become a thorn oh he's a great thorn
isn't he he's dead he's a dead pug
that's what you call him Forks that's
just a classic time burner that has no
point whatsoever I should probably go
back or does he oh my goodness
could I do something constructive okay
this is working or is it nope okay I got
to go in a different direction
get my king out of danger okay come over
here I have absolutely nothing
absolutely nothing that nights gonna
kill me gonna throw a check in okay I'm
kind of happy with that why am I so
happy with that
oh that wasn't a good thing to do was it
check let's do this I want to break oh
my goodness I only have three seconds
any time burners
I had made I had made oh my goodness
they forfeit on time I lost track of
time
I don't know I never even paid attention
to the time forget about I never yes in
order to lose track of time you have to
know how much time you have I never at
any point even knew how much time I had
there I have to look I have to look to
see first I have to look to see first
this guy never falls for the h2 stuff
I've played this guy so much and he
never fell for it yet I am persistent
yet I am persistent I will keep trying I
will try to get in that every time here
we go pile up on that night get my
Bishop on b7 get him on b7 I still have
thoughts of what still have I just want
that night to move ok light-square
weaknesses can I get there LightSquared
bishop I could o with check the ship
takes I recapture with the Queen
sneakiness everywhere sneakiness
unprotected pieces that bishop is having
a tough day now ok can i let's do this
take with check and then i can give up
this bishop because I have made threats
on g2 Bishop takes Queen takes if King
moves Knight f3 rook takes Queen takes
threatening on g2 I got the Queen ok
pawn push probably no ok I still do this
rook here's the only move I want a
castle
you got should have I can't take the pun
they still can't take the pun now they
can take the pun yeah yeah ok I should
just give this back
Nate's right again I should be trying to
deflect that rook
here no matter what pack determine 27 20
20 20 oh okay
22 minutes remaining okay
Queens off and I'm up a pond and I have
a fork threat the rook is dead Knight
out get castled nope they resigned back
to term at 39 20 20 20 here we go here
we go here no matter what here no matter
what pawn takes I have a queen check and
if pond takes here I have this but I
don't know what the great follow up is I
guess this pawn push if there's more
pressure placed on my knight if he's
taken I have a connected passed pawn and
I robbed this night of that square the F
okay this is what I was talking about so
now
let's go here is pond is court it has to
be a great inconvenience clean up and
then if the night plays here I take this
or I could pin the night I cap in that
night my night needs to do something
else
it's dude this may make you get a bishop
check-in the nights just gonna move
actually or is it
let's pin that night let's pin that
night and then attack the pin to peace
I'm okay with tonight here I'll just
drop my Bishop back no I don't want to
go backwards I'm going forwards you're
gonna take that pawn there's gotta be
something really good for me feel it
okay I'm getting a pun
26:21 my night worst place peace he
needs to get working I take him out and
jump my knight in here clean I'm here to
pin this off for a queen exchange I
didn't want to do that I wanted to play
here cuz then I would be on the bishop
I could still do this I'm on the Queen
that's working out that was still
available know keep my knight right
where he's out right here my knight and
pawn work very well together okay no how
are we gonna make progress King up here
here they're down on time back to termen
53 30 30 28 um still very early on 19
minutes remain you might get some free
gift stuff going on here so this is I'm
reminded of the same oh this reminded of
the Simon from earlier secured my bishop
that's what I'm stopping night night
before stuff so my night is gonna go on
a little journey or is he
okay my center is collapsing and I'm in
big trouble okay pawn push iPod push
back for lack of better words okay oh
boy it is difficult situation I'm
finding myself in pawn push why not okay
this is an issue I could get this I'm
back to being okay and back to okay I'm
better regain material my bishops are
monsters dark square bishop in
particular I'll take with the pawn to
watch overnight pivots here well that
was stupid move if I'm gonna retake my
pot and I my rook is on a closed file I
should have been doing this I still have
it get some material and then maybe take
on e6 depending on how there's a
recapture okay I think King takes would
have been better the Queen's are off
this Knight is boxed out he might jump
in here but I play off three let's just
do this right now maybe I should have
gotten on the other open file so I'm I'm
controlling the rook by having control
over both open files
expand with my double pawn King position
now this nights gonna jump in here I
should have addressed that this is a pin
and then soon enough a win take this
pawn first and then it's a one king upon
endgame came here in less than seven
seconds they resigned back to turn at 69
fifty five forty forty thirty um there's
a lot of guys right on my heels a lot of
them let's go with this cuz it's
different a little bit different okay I
shouldn't have done that I'm probably
close to being trapped alright
close to being trapped okay I could get
this in and then this push its castle I
think I might want to do c6 no a6 I take
let's defend this could take in the play
night here let's do that get that dark
square Bishop back although it could
drop back and then my opponent could
work on flushing light nights away I
think I want to get an f5 stop c5 okay
I'd love to get rid of this night and
then get to this Square stop b4 for the
moment pawn push here grant okay now
this was premature you needed a baby
step it now what this means is that
there's not a good pawn break to get in
from my opponent on the Queen side I
could put it to a great health with rook
a five-night b3 would be needed to take
like this and then actually Knight g6 to
here although I'm gonna do this move
first I don't want the night to be able
to make use of this square let's get rid
of the knight and then my knight is
gonna be a monster on this square
however he might play here and maybe
should have good night versus bad Bishop
and I think I can get these guys rolling
my G and H pawn and this covered
my queen doing something pressure on
this as well let's keep marching
oh the rook the rook could actually go
there that's a pivot point the bishop is
there yeah I missed that detail very
important detail if you got that pawn
9 seconds
King position oh oh sure take it out
there down on time back determine 87-73
64-54
oh oh this is one of the guys that's up
there this is one of the guys that's up
there alright they're gonna get an
expansion with b5 and maybe I should
have played this first okay Knight b6 I
think this is working out before I could
take and I could take the night with
check okay so this is working out bishop
here I'm getting getting the rook the
very least I'm getting the rook with my
knight out of the way and then do what
exactly
No let's just drop back get my light
squared bishop doing something point
right here they were stopping this pawn
push I guess they could force the
situation just gonna open up I should
have played yeah that wasn't the
direction to go in
okay what's castle on this point now oh
they missed that this is crumbling now
very quickly it's a check
where's that King go
don't drop your clean whatever you do
don't drop that clean they're close to
being paralyzed they resigned back
determine 107 93 7063 halfway point 14
minutes remain
14 minutes remain if I played this guy
before damn certain Oh getting a pond
and then the bishop pair on the Queen
that's a free piece getting here next on
the Queen the skit kitchen-sink
variation kitchen sink throne a check no
matter what there's that me mate soon 1
2 3 no no no 1 2 3 4 okay back to
tournament 1:27 93-88 67 13 minutes
remaining
she taco 'if water and then f4 get these
nights out in this night look to damage
the structure and then focus on
maintaining a light square pond chain
since I don't have my light square
Bishop around to do that job so I kick
tonight avoid the night exchange and
then play see for that that would be in
particular if the night played to d5
this Bishop is a dead piece and I feel
like there should be an attack Knight g5
happening soon hitting a lot of stuff
each 76 with fork take with the knight
main threats
well I should just take it a night it's
in a pen could still do that I could
take like this for a second I was gonna
take with my rook Queen trade
and what next they don't have this the
bishop isn't there on g2 I'm not them
though
check my rooks working get the Queen's
off if these Queens off guarding this
pawn I want to target this next phase
pawn I'm gonna do this first put him
taking the rook
it's a mate in one two three the rook
has to block after the King moves back
to tournament 147 123 108 11 minutes pie
pans again all right go into some gambit
nope
I grabbed some space in the center with
tempo maybe f5 as well
these Knights can be kicked around quite
easily he develops okay a pawn push
happening soon both Knights are
controlling all four center squares I'm
okay with doubled pawns get my
development in oh I wasn't okay with
giving that up can work themselves into
a pin if Knight takes bishop here
another just down a piece let's break
down the pom it's in my territory very
cramping just get rid of their dark
square Bishop it's their best piece so
Queen Queen e7 Division and Bishop e5 is
what I was planning I show them down
that Queen takes it's not going to be
made but it is now f2 1 67 123 108 108
10 minute warning
um okay ten-minute warning and been here
before okay winter why go with this
context okay I'm gonna try to get here
d6 with check and actually the whole fun
is falling pretty much when the Queen I
take this pond although Knight takes
pawn is available now it's not actually
I don't even know if it was to begin
with
so this is a good center I'm looking to
take out that night what's the story
with that miscalculation maybe take that
night out castle and undermine the black
center pawn push probably pawn push
again no let's do it like this take that
night away I want to open this position
up no tricky Forks I mean takes Knight
Queen takes Knight actually this is
better and then I could get the knight
later unless the Queen blocks back to
tournament I was gonna take the rook and
then take on a 7 and then take the
knight but the Queen will probably block
on d7 oh oh oh oh watch out super fast
John Madden is here and I should not
have allowed that pond advance okay that
pond is a giant thorn giant thorn so
let's try and keep things closed
actually can I get this in it's very
tempting to just give up a pawn right
there okay
the plan here is to get my knight into
this square take this out and then I
want to establish but with kit and now
I'm gonna take with this
that night is gonna kill me hopefully
this works it's not gonna work my rook
is in big trouble
eirick is pinned on that pond is this
kind of looking my rook is in a tough
tough spot not anymore though okay oh
that's not a good idea they got a pig
there they have a giant pig with a check
queen block defend that my dark square
bishop needs to do something yeah I have
to get rid of this rook it's too much of
a pain okay no it's very scary actually
a lot of pressure on me watch out for
that tricky night
time burners whoa Oh actually had a
pretty decent image back to tournament
207 they were down on time 207 161 oh
they're usually a 1 that is forcing me
on the ropes with regard to time Wow I
couldn't even assess that I could not
even assess that position I got to to
wild way to while the light-square
bishop SAR coming off the board and if I
could get a pawn on f5 I think that
would be wonderful
oh I'd get trapped if I do that Queen
here Bishop here I think I'm trapped on
push yep
okay I have a decent Center and then
we're getting killed by the computer
recently with some variation like this
not that pun I don't want to take it
just you I could do this that's that's
March that's March here
I'll push next now I'm gonna drop this I
have a giant's i-220 majority now Oh
pawn push now I have a check Bishop here
next and then something against their
king hopefully 25 Oh Queen here Queen
here threatens Bishop takes pawn
I got Bishop Queen takes pawn stuff this
seems right connected pass pawn queen
here next main threat making one threat
mmm back to tournament
227 they missed that 227 181 that pond
was pinned King a jg7 was powerless as
soon as that happened guess we'll do
this so I'm not losing time by capturing
it my queen and just defend my knight
and also what f7 stuff so I'm on there
Bishop my knight is gonna be pouncing on
this square with tempo and I want to get
my light square Bishop freed up you take
like this so my darks red Bishop
couldn't contribute pawn push to break
this down
there's central pawn now he's passed get
this Bishop out right here just double
up on the F file Oh dark square
weaknesses looking to smash through at
this point my knight is the one who
could use some work he wants to be the
one on g3 not my Bishop Bishop takes
pawn is not available
my Queen was defended by my bishop just
defend stuff for a little bit okay the
rook is dead and have this square under
control
Queen here to here next other knights
gonna move
should move I have this score covered
bishops there
it's easy to miss Queen check here I
take this first now I just go here not
Bishop check it's still there I could do
counter-attack
I could take here I could take the
knight if Bishop blocks this is working
out one material just then I don't want
to move my bishop that's on g3 for
seconds they resigned back to tournament
247 201 198 3 minutes remaining
this guy isn't even gonna movies at
negative 59 right I guess he's not
moving um this is gonna be a quick win
then double the points back to
tournament 267 267 221 198 3 minutes 19
seconds space rap all right
Lopez Gaucho none of the above okay they
get they're not getting their deep on
contributing although now they could
successfully fishing pole fishing pole
in effect will it be taken is the big
question
okay I'm gonna reposition my night he's
stupid on c6 cuz the pond is boxing him
out so eventually I want to pivot on e6
keep this night away a little bit there
Bishop is close to dead in fact it is
dead it is dead right now they have to
sack material the night has to take or
that okay defend my bishop but they
really take that and help me develop I
have pressure on this more pressure on
it I feel like I have something takes
and then g3 is there and this this this
h-file is going to actually be quite
devastating am I not gonna be takin this
row can't move this is gonna be tough Oh
a night here it's not there now
double-check me I know there won't be a
double-check named IRA can move with
check though this rook is pin now I'm on
the night everything is hanging there
this rook has gone very close to me here
one two three four two three and then
four they're down on time back determine
287 to 41 to 38 D for another benoni
you for him a six and meet with what
exactly
actually this is quite strong to be
taking on that five and then developing
the bishop okay take like this get my
rook on a half-open file this pawn is
probably gonna fall
or is it oh my goodness are you kidding
me oh what a terrible mouth slip Oh take
here please oh my goodness oh my
goodness oh this is such a bad Mouse
limb why did you do that oh please
please please work it save the day light
square bishop whatever you do save the
day
oh my opponents give me more material I
could defend this now I could defend
this more material what am i doing get
out of that what's the time
I got to take that pond out he was too
dangerous come on
why was my moving tricky night Oh are
they doing time fighters they just drop
the Queen oh wow did I dodged a bullet
there a quick left three no baby what
did I really mean to do I promise I did
not want to drop my queen like that Oh
they called the tournament I'm not gonna
get to see the end of this one oh man
what a surprise
298 why there was a buzzer beater I was
like oh yeah I got it in the bag oh I
snuck right up on me
298 287 239 237 very nice the games
uh-oh
okay